Juan's in New York he says I've been
engaged for three months and we're
getting married in August I want us to
be on the same page financially when's a
good time for me to introduce her to
Financial Peace University you're late
you should have already introduced her
on the second date I'm kidding but yeah
not much listen the number one cause of
divorce in North America today is fights
over money and money stress and money
problems if it's the number one cause of
divorce whatever it is you address that
in pre marriage counseling deeply deeply
address it because you know if you're on
completely different pages with money
that tells us if you don't get on the
same page prior to getting married you
are going to struggle in your marriage a
hundred percent of the time all of us
struggle on our marriages but I mean
you're gonna have real struggles okay I
haven't met a lady what she said we been
married 32 years and we've never had a
fight and I said it's because you lie of
course you had a fight in 32 even
married 32 minutes you gotta fight
believe that stuff but I'll tell you
what a lot of pastors and a lot of
friends and a lot of marriage counselors
are using Financial Peace University the
nine week you know course at your church
to as a part of a pre-marriage
counseling because it forces you could
talk through everything investing your
views on wealth your views on doctrine
regarding wealth your views on paying
bills your views on buying stuff you
can't afford money you don't have to
impress people you don't really like you
figure out if you're marrying the
princess you figure out if you're
marrying a guy who won't work you find
these things out when you start talking
about money and these are disturbing
things to find out after marriage so we
strongly recommend it of course we're
big believers but lots of people are
doing it as part of a marriage
counseling with a pre-marriage
counseling rhythm